hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a comparative study of
turnaround times for common haematic
pathology panels on the life of
Biosystems bond 3 and the roast tissue
Diagnostics benchmark older instruments
I am Alexis Krause of lab routes and
I'll be our moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lappers and brought to you
by like a bio system to learn more about
our sponsor please visit
www.sap.com/learnbi for hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker David
Roche bond product manager at Leica
Biosystems and Melissa Boyd global
support applications team lead at Leica
Biosystems for a complete biography on
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen David and
Melissa you may now begin your
presentation
okay thanks Alysa Alexis so we'll start
off with the presentation as an Alexis
headset welcome to today's webinar and
we'll be taking a look at the results of
a study we did earlier this year on the
comparative turnaround times of the bomb
tree and the benchmark ultra my name is
David Roach I'll take you through the
first bit and then hand over to Melissa
to talk about workflow a bit later on
and we'll get into the nuts and bolts of
the study
you
so here are the contents they'll closely
follow the contents of the study that we
conducted earlier this year but as I
said before we get into the nuts and
bolts of the study it is worthwhile
spending a few minutes taking a look at
some of the some of the complexities
around the anatomic pathology workflow
in general and IFC workflow in
particular and I said please are put in
as many questions as you as you can and
we'll have some time hopefully at the
end for either myself or Melissa to
answer those questions
the last 10 to 15 years there has been
an increasing focus on health care costs
across the globe as exemplified by
things such as the affordable affordable
care act and our anatomic pathology
laboratories are not immune from this
often having to perform a delicate
balancing acts of budget constraints and
just sheer volume of work sometimes
without compromising on quality and as a
result of these external drivers some
pathology associations have attempted to
provide guidance on key performance
metrics to improve patient care and one
of these metrics is the timeliness of
the patient reporting as a measure of
the lab performance and efficiency and
our industry has adopted certain
elements of the Toyota Production system
methodology to improve quality reduce
the turnaround times for patients and
reduce costs and the time it takes to
complete the single piece the patient
case has become an increasingly
important unit of measurement on the
face of it as you can see here the
workflow can seem deceptively simple you
get the request you put the slides into
a stainer stay in the slides you collate
the slides and then send them back to
the pathologist problem is this
superficial workflow simplicity is
rarely rarely the reality and in
anatomic pathology a further
complication of this single piece flow
concept is the reality that a patient
case is commonly ordered as a series of
slides and the pathologist ordinarily
requires the full set of slides per
patient before moving to make a report
and the number of slides in a patient
case is most extreme in the humanistic
chemistry workflow case requests in IHC
are ordered as a series of tests with
multiple antibodies and slides often
referred to as a panel and providing
pathologists with all of their requested
panel at once allows them to conduct a
report in one sitting and pathologists
typically wait for all of the slides in
the panel before reviewing and reporting
so here we can see a stylized example of
the full workflow of histology sample
right from the receipt of the sample of
the front-end all the way through to the
pathologist's report there are multiple
steps to simply get to the pathologist
in a changi or hematoxylin and eosin
slide or a series of HTS and there are
significant manual and automated
elements within the process and also the
opportunity for variations in the wage
led tackles each step along the way
in addition immunohistochemistry is
often an add-on test after examination
of the routine stains increasing the
total turnaround time of reporting and
often pushing turnaround times past some
of the injured industry metrics it's a
really complex workflow and many moving
parts and each one of these steps is a
touch point a person a cost an
opportunity for error and a waiting
point if staff aren't available and so
what is vitally important to note here
when it comes to completing a panel to
be reviewed by a pathologist in terms of
measuring turnaround times it is the
last slide of the panel that matters so
here I'm going to hand over to Melissa
to talk about some of the different ways
that we can do workflow within anatomic
pathology before we get into the study
so over to you Melissa okay thanks for
that David before we get into the study
detail I think it's just worth taking a
bit of time to have a general look at
how someone's get through that I hate C
workload so the two main ones are batch
and continuous here on this slide we've
have an illustrated form of that
workflow so this has got quite clear
cutoff times and new work but run times
and completion times as well ordinarily
the cutoff time for each batch to start
running would be well communicated
across the web to this pathologist and
the rest of staff and as you would
expect the times for the completed tasks
to be to be well known for everyone so
as you can see there are both advantages
and limitations to this general workflow
so in general its value in terms of
predictability is sort of counterbalance
with its relative in flexibility in
terms of workflows functions
so let's just go to the next slide here
and now going to talk about our
continuous workflow so on this next
graph we've got Illustrated a form of
continuous workflow so in its purest
form here each panel of requests would
be dealt with as soon as that arrived
and the lab would be able to undertake
all of the prep prep the prep steps
almost immediately in order to get the
test running again just like that
workflow there are both advantages and
limitations to this form of workflow so
to be truly continuous the anatomical
lab would probably need to be running 24
hours so no matter when the request came
in they could deal with them immediately
so they would avoid sort of a large
buildup of slides that need to be
batched so there are some 24 hour loves
out there and thankfully I'm not anyone
the complexity of the anatomical
pathology workflow doesn't lend itself
easily to continuous workflow as we saw
earlier there are so many steps prior to
the standing of a slide or a panel of
slides and there still it needs to be a
pathologist on hand once they're
completed or we've always completed all
the slides in order to complete the full
workflow
though a study by the American College
of pathologists indicated that 80% of
labs had in place a midday come up for
requests to be completed the same day
this is an indication of just how
prevalent at least some forms about
protein processing still is in the
anatomical pathology world to
counterbalance this with a separate
study that suggests 94 percent of
respondents preferred to complete the
IHC standing on the same day the request
and you can start to see some of the
challenges labs face in meeting these
twin demands of having the same D
testing and workload management
especially for any requests that arise
later than midday
so now we can have a look at our work
flow comparisons to antibody or per
panel so a lab could also make a
determination on how they group the
individual tests within a case by either
keeping the cases together or within the
case us cases up into their requisite
tests once again you see both have
advantages and limitations of either
method
so just let's have a look at the
complexity on our next slide here
so as you can see here we've got a lot
of inputs and causes so when we take all
of this into consideration the how and
the when the requests arrived the
complexity of the requests what the
staffing and shift patterns look like
throughout the day how skilled the staff
our instrumentation being used all those
sort of things we can start to see that
there are so many inputs that a lab
needs to consider before implementing a
workflow solution that fits their
situation so once we think about all of
the inputs the batch and continuous
processing now that was talked about
that let's pass over to David and he can
continue on
thanks Melissa so we'll have a quick
look at trying to navigate automation
before we get into into the study you
can see that there's a lot of different
solutions out there there's a whole
bunch of features to choose from before
you even get to the decision-making
process of what's going to fit your lab
so there's things like targeting
efficiency slow turnaround time and
throughput but the impact of these
combined features on case and panel
turnaround times is actually quite
difficult to assess on paper and the
relative value each of you will place on
a feature or a set of features will
definitely differ from from lab to lab
and even from person to person depending
on your circumstances that you bring to
the decision-making process so the
purpose of this study was to examine I
guess the relative panel turnaround
times of the BOM 3 and the benchmark
ultra fully automated is the instruments
since the panel turnaround time is is
one way that we can in fact try to
measure led lab efficiency so here is
here we have the full abstract of the
study so that you can familiarize
yourself with its focus and scope so
just reiterate this study compares the
turnaround times of 10 common meta
pathology panels for two leading IHC
slide stain systems at the bomb 3 and
the rush tissue Diagnostics benchmark
ultra I would like to make it clear at
this point that the sole focus of this
study was to compare turnaround times
and as you'll see and here later in the
presentation no actual tissue was
stained and so we draw no conclusions as
far as this study is concerned on the
relative quality of the stained slide
that would be produced from either
instrument
so for this study we chose to focus on a
lab workflow that is essentially of a
batching case-based design this is a
reasonably common workflow for IOT labs
and it does allow for an element of
predictability in terms of cut up cutoff
times inventory control and staff
resourcing in this scenario it doesn't
particularly matter how and when the
requests are received either in big
batches or continuous smaller requests
as the workflow paradigm dictates how
and when the instrument we run
importantly this workflow method does
allow for an element of walk away time
for the staff the lab staff can be freed
up for other important tasks within the
lab and the workflow graphic on this
page is not a precise representation of
the study method it's merely to
illustrate more broadly what a batching
workflow may look like in a lab with two
to three runs per day as well as an
overnight run and this is a quite common
way of
of determining how to do your work so
whilst there are most certainly other
basic workflow methodologies and each
lab will often have its own unique twist
on the fundamental design this design
was chosen to this study for a number of
reasons it allowed us to make a design
or a study design that was relevant to
many laboratories it made it quite easy
to set up and describe it's reproducible
so you could set up this study for
yourselves if you wanted to verify the
results it reduced variables such as
needing to swap out reagents and or
antibodies mid-run it avoided having to
use the ultimate reagent access software
feature on the benchmark ultra which may
have extended the turn around the panel
turnaround times and it enabled an
efficient use of reagent inventory and
avoided requiring greater than one rtu
container or dispenser per antibody to
be in active use and that is quite
common within labs
always only having one of one particular
antibody open so the overall approach
allowed us to undertake a like-for-like
analysis of turnaround times for each
individual tunnel
you
so this study as mentioned earlier
comprises ten panels which a
representative of common human a
pathology disease states and these were
selected based on worldwide incident
rates of hematopathologist bodies chosen
for each of the ten disease states were
taken principally from recommendations
published by the National Comprehensive
Cancer Network or the NC C n the end
NCCN is a not-for-profit alliance of 27
leading cancer organizations and is
globally recognized for its leadership
in creating best practice clinical
guidelines and resources for patients
clinicians and other healthcare
decision-makers in this study or in this
study should I say the panels are
referred to as team panels one through
to ten and whilst the panels do
represent common test requests by
pathologists to diagnose real disease
states
we can't name them basically because we
manufacture many of the antibodies used
and we need to avoid implying any
particular diagnostic utility that would
extend beyond the baited instructions
for use that's why we refer to these as
panels and don't don't specifically name
them each panel was made up of between
six to eleven anybodies each and across
the board will use utilizing 24
different antibodies within the ten
panels and the total was 88 slides 23
out of the 24 antibodies were taken from
the NCCN guidelines and the 24th
antibody was recommended for inclusion
into 10 panel 5 by Lu SLE the
composition of each panel as you can see
in the table shown here were chosen for
three main reasons
if you view both the likely Biosystems
and the rush tissue Diagnostics websites
both fenders arranged around your bodies
in terms of pathology menu and both have
a have a heme panel
hiim panel exhibit quite a significant
variation in terms of panel size and so
as a relevant study of single piece flow
the range of sizes within the heme
panels can really push the boundaries of
ensuring the single place flow or the
single piece flow methodology is
effective and lastly it just seems as
good a place as any to start so given
the ten panels form a common cohort of
requests from General Hospital's to
Academical academic centers to
specialist reference centers why not
start here so for this study the slides
were processed in three separate runs to
reflect the common lab workflow known as
batching and the slides for a new batch
only start after all slides from the
initial batch has finished and each ran
each instrument should I say ran around
identical batches
you
the each required marker are ready to
use or rtu antibody tied to the staining
instrument along with the factory
recommended protocols were used wherever
possible although the protocols were
selected by RT recommendations for both
the bond and the benchmark instruments
dearly winced or water was used as a
substitute for the actual reagent
so the bond 320 of the 24 antibodies
were available in the bond r2u format
and as you can see in the table for
antibodies were not available in the rtu
format ordinarily in these instances if
a lab offers still offer that particular
test they will source the antibody
either as a concentrate and then the
optimizer themselves or they would send
them out more likely they would optimize
them as a concentrate
and for these for antibodies including
the pretreatment and the incubation
times these were taken from an external
clinical laboratory where they were in
regularly regular use for the benchmark
ultra 22 of the 24 antibodies were
available in our to you format and for
one of them cdas we've skipped out one
particular step the ultra block step
simply because we didn't have room on
the reagent carousel for the reagent so
this meant going against the factory
recommended protocol for cd8 but since
this study wasn't focused on quality the
workflow we felt this was a reasonable
change to make and in any case it did
make the protocol for cd8 slightly
shorter so it had no impact on the end
result the other two antibodies not
available in the AR to you for that we
used the shortest protocol in the panel
that they were part of to ensure that
they didn't impact the overall
turnaround time either for the benchmark
system ordinarily or primarily offers
two different detection systems the
octave view and the ultra ultra view for
each antibody the detection system list
listed in their ifu was chosen and
wherever the ifu listed both the Optive
u detection system was selected as this
represents their newest detection
technology available for the benchmark
instruments the instruments were
preloaded with all of the reagents and
slides to allow all slides to be started
together as would be the case in a batch
workflow the bomb 3 tests were performed
here in melbourne while like abaya
systems the benchmark ultra tests were
performed by an experienced third-party
testing organization and both
instruments were operated in or in
accordance with their respective
operator instructions and the instrument
software versions are recorded in the
white paper that was better just to get
through all those kind of bits and
pieces just so you know how to study
with with run
okay so the turnaround time calculation
slide versus case the turnaround time
calculations you can see here in simple
terms we timed runs from the time the
panel was started on the instrument to
when the panel was finished on the
instrument and for the individual slow
turnaround times the same thing but
measured at the file level no the
complete panel level we didn't include
any of the pre-processing time such as
the time it takes to enter all of the
slide details slide labeling placing the
slides on instruments reagent setup etc
and nor do we include any of the
post-processing time removal of the
liquid cover slips cover slipping etc
the main reason for this is these tasks
were considered to open to
interpretation and variability amongst
individual operators in terms of
ensuring the study was fair and unbiased
it's got to say they're not important
but for us it was outside the scope of
the study
you
now let's look at the results so
to resolve we can see here is the panel
turnaround time the time it took the
time it takes to complete all of the
slides within each team panel
have a look at that spreader here the
pedal turnaround times on the bomb three
were really consistent ranging from only
149 minutes to 156 minutes so seven
minutes spread whereas the panel
turnaround times on the benchmark ultra
varied more broadly with the range
spreading from 189 minutes up to to 250
minutes or over four hours so you take
these that as an average the respective
mean internal mean panel turnaround time
for the bomb three was two hours 33 and
for the benchmark ultra three hours 59
and the bomb three one-hour was on
average 120 126 one hour 26 minutes
faster than the benchmark ultra or 36%
faster three of the 10 panels were more
than 100 minutes faster on the bomb
three compared to the benchmark ultra
and eight of the 10 panels we're between
93 and 101 minutes faster team panel 5
had the smallest difference in main
panel turnaround time with the bomb 3
being 33 minutes so now we'll look at
the results from the individual
turnaround time or individual slide
turnaround time perspective the average
slide turnaround time for the markers on
the bomb 3 was 146 minutes and the
average turnaround time for the markers
on the benchmark ultra was 164 minutes a
difference of only 18 minutes
however the variability was much higher
on the benchmark ultra across all
markers turnaround times on the
benchmark ultra showed 148 minutes
spread
two hours 28 minutes spread while the
bomb three kept a really narrow
distribution of spread of only 17
minutes
so this wide distribution of individual
antibody completion times on the on the
benchmark ultra with 65% of the
antibodies tested taking longer than the
longest bond 3 antibody this is the
reason why the benchmark ultra panels
took on average over an hour and a half
longer to complete than the bomb 3 so
just as a reminder it's the side with
the slowest to turnaround time that
determines when the panel is completed
and then when the whole thing can go can
be sent to the pathologist for review
so if we dig a little deeper into link
between individual antibody turnaround
times and panel turnaround times it's
worth noting that eight out of the ten
panels specified CD 10 as one of the
markers and CD 10 has the longest
turnaround time on the benchmark ultra a
little over four hours there's no single
feature I would say that makes the bomb
three generally faster than the
benchmark ultra but if you look at the
length of the adjutant retrieval steps
it's a reasonably good predictor in
terms of turnaround time the one and a
half hour step for the CD 10 on the
benchmark ultra doesn't compare
particularly favorably in terms of
turnaround time with the 20 minute
retrieval step on the bomb 3 when both
protocols are run to the manufacturers
guidelines panel for which you can see
here didn't contain CD 10 and we're
still 49 minutes slower overall with 6
out of the 7 antibodies having a longer
turnaround time on the benchmark ultra
then the bombs free
so another way we can measure efficiency
is the time elapsed or the time it took
to process all 88 slides on the
instruments the BOM 3 was able to
process three batches totaling the 88
slides within six within within eight
hours or actually around seven hours or
seven point six hours while the
benchmark ultra completed the same three
batches in 12 and a half hours so this
data would indicate that you could get
an additional run at up to four of these
kinds of tunnels essentially another
full batch on the BOM three in the same
time it took for the benchmark ultra to
run the 88 slides or to put it another
way a 36% efficiency advantage for the
bomb three instrument well if you look
at it from the viewport the viewpoint of
a complete shift when we consider things
like over time the bomb 3 would allow
all 10 team panels tested in this study
to be completed within an eight hour
period whereas the benchmark ultra would
only complete seven out of the ten so
this would represent a 30% increase in
the number of cases ready for diagnosis
within the standard eight-hour shift and
while there's absolutely true there are
a number of ways to set up an IC
workflow within the lab there may be
really sound reasons while there needs
to adopt a batch workflow methods such
as inventory management and management
of staff resources so this study showed
that under the test conditions described
here the BOM 3 is able to complete the
four panels up to 40% faster than the
benchmark ultra offering a
predictability in panel completion times
at or around two and a half hours and
that would allow the lab to manage their
resources and most importantly play
their parts in rapid case reporting and
permitting clinicians to quickly provide
patients with some certainty
on to the summary so case reporting
timeliness is is the one metric of lab
efficiency and performance with IEC
eliminate history chemistry recognized
as a process that really can impact this
mess this metric this study shows that
the bonteri instrument process
common team panels up to 40% faster than
the benchmark ultra which would allow
pathologists to review cases in a timely
manner and quickly order additional
tests if required
in addition allowing more slides and
panels to be seen within a shift thereby
reducing either panel waiting time or
panel yes panel waiting time or staff
overtime or potentially both a patient
case not an individual slide is the true
single plea single piece in the process
that defines efficiency and process
quality therefore the turnaround time of
the last slide of a case is a critical
measurement of efficiency in this study
the bonteri delivered the last slide
faster than the benchmark culture in all
of the panel's tested so most
importantly I hope that this webinar
gives you some food for thoughts in
determining what is what it is that your
lab truly needs in order to make a
difference to team productivity led
management and ultimately I guess the
ultra Beatrice II and the timeliness of
the diagnostic reports and feature lists
rarely provide a real understanding of
how a solution might be suitable or how
it may fit each unique situation
especially in a complex environment like
an anatomic pathology laboratory where
there are still many manual and many
automated components so I would very
much add you to do as much research as
possible and wherever possible try
before you buy
so that concludes the webinar
I guess we're ready now to take some
questions Alexis if any have come
through
yes thank you David and Melissa for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is what would happen to
the bond 3 turnaround times if the IHC
request from the pathologist didn't
arrive in nice neat batches that
effectively allowed you to fill up each
instrument
so I'll take this one Melissa yeah
there'll be differences that's that's
Airy so that's an excellent question one
of the reasons the form of batching is
still so prevalent in anatomic pathology
is that the quick the requests do arrive
that non predictable non uniform rate
depends on what clinics are going on
traffic there's a whole bunch of factors
I'll show you one of the previous slides
you hold on one minute I'll get back to
it
one
yeah this one so this particular
workflow does try to deal with some of
the lumpiness in the way the requests
come in by having certain cutoff times
and so this allows the lab to optimize
in to some extent to manage the way that
will manage their workload I guess so
there are multiple ways to deal with
each and every workflow but we just
wanted to make sure when we're doing
this comparison that it was fair and
unbiased and so that's why we designed
the study the way it is by and large the
BOM three had turnaround times of two
and a half hours per antibody across the
board which is pretty consistent
considering you're over 20 different
antibodies in the study but it will be
really great to run this kind of study
on your particular circumstances and in
fact that's probably only the real way
the only real way to know what solution
is better for you and if these findings
would hold true for your particular set
of circumstances I'm confident they
would but the proof of the pudding will
most certainly be in the eating I guess
so if you'd like to get in contact
outside this meeting I'd be happy to
speak to you about how a similar study
could be set up in your lab we'd be more
than happy to do that
let's go to our next question
I'm sorry is it asked the question I
believe it did so let's move on to our
next one have you tried to see how the
results would change if you move to a
continuous workflow
so that's it's another really excellent
question
in short no but it would be really
interesting to see one of the reasons we
did set this study of the way that we
have is it meant we took out a fair bit
of the complexity when we think about
each instrument so we could make it fair
and unbiased for example loading all the
reagents are prior to us starting maybe
we didn't have to try and work with the
benchmark ultras reagent access software
and it was difficult to predict from run
to run when it would give us access to
the reagent carousel so we didn't want
to I guess negatively influence their
results by adding this variable into the
mix I think it's just either the
previous answer I'd love to hear from
any of you if you'd like to undertake
this kind of study using your particular
set of circumstances and I guess really
kick the tires of whether these
particular finding called up for your
particular set of circumstances I would
add that we do hear from a lot of people
they are running a continuous workflow
but when you dig a little deeper there's
often a series of cut-off times just
because we're continually all doing
something involved in getting these
requests for the to the pathologist
doesn't necessarily mean we're running a
truly continuous workflow and if there's
something about the complex nature of
the anatomic pathology workflow that
kind of sets it apart from the other
pathologist disciplines it's kind of
well got it into it in the first place
and made it so rewarding it's a
wonderful mix of art and science
okay yes a dozen it looks like we have
time for just one more question today
why didn't you also assess the quality
yeah so that's that's another really
interesting question I was kind of
wondering when that one would come up so
there's two main reasons we used our to
use in the study as you saw wherever
possible and this implies a certain
level of quality of this of the stained
slide anyway from from both us and and
from Ventana or from russia uh saying
there are other studies out there
eternal EQ a scheme that deal with the
question of quality so we actually felt
it would be more meaningful that we
added to the topic of panel turnaround
times to the wider debate instead of you
know adding adding to the the debate
about quality and again I would say
quality in many cases in is in the eye
of the beholder when it comes to IHC so
we would be very very happy to run these
kinds of studies in your particular lab
with your particular circumstances with
your particular slides and everything
else to see one if the quality matches
your expectations and to whether the
turnaround time results also hold up
within your particular set of
circumstances so that's why we didn't do
a quality assessment as as well
you
and actually you still write one love
what sorry one last piece there so when
when we go around various labs and speak
to pathologists and lab managers they
always absolutely wanted within focused
on quality that is the number one metric
that people are interested in and I
would have to say by and large people
reasonably happy with whichever vendor
they choose when it comes when it comes
to quality when when the instruments
work but what messes them and what keeps
them up at night is trying to work out
how they're going to get through those
slides whilst maintaining their quality
so that's why we thought we would focus
on workflow and turnaround time thank
you David and Melissa do either you have
any final comments for our audience
no nothing else for me thank you
so just just one final thought like it
is it is really difficult to look at a
set of features for instrumentation
especially an anatomic pathology where
is still a largely manual element to it
so I really do
very much urge you all to not just look
at what we all say on paper but try and
understand how these pieces of
instrument or how these machines how
these tools will work for you and your
particular sentence a set of
circumstances and most certainly try
before you buy
not every machine fits every situation
thank you again David Roche and Melissa
Boyd for your time today and your
important research so if we would also
like to thank labyrinth and our sponsor
like a Biosystems for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through April of
2019 laboratory alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye